we try and do like two or three days
because any more than that I can't stick
with but we try and like schedule
schedule today yeah cuz some days you
just wake him but I want it off too late
yeah
jet ski or [ __ ] jump off a building
I'm trying to get Joe Schilling to
skydive with me he's deathly afraid of
heights I would never do that either
why Liz I go through this gallery this
difference should mean you I go pros and
cons pros I have to get time to bill
it's a fun time man you experience I'm
cool Han died I yeah what do you know
about a been skydiving
I've how many not many you don't know
many well you know me and I'm still
alive yeah you're crazy dude you never
you never hear me like oh man
he went skydiving and died - no but you
only hear that they're not like always
guys got another one this is but you
know so do you jump out by yourself or
yeah of course
no so that's how my dude on your back
[ __ ] no how am I gonna how could I or
all my girl or not you know I couldn't
put a picture on a fridge with another
dude behind my girl so fun ya know so I
went to my very first jump with solo
I went took all the classes and
everything yeah there's no way I was
like we jump solo well you've never done
it before
yeah I just it's the only way to test
you gotta like go through these courses
and and yeah I heard if you're over 225
pounds though you have to jump so low so
like my big ass I'm not gonna have big
Gary on my back with 500 per year I
can't do it so I heard that my weight
like its trouble like though the
parachutes aren't built for big dudes
right did you ever take that
consideration I'm also I'm not a big
dude I'm like right in the middle I just
but where you go when you jump and
you're not so low usually with her like
a group yes well so I made Greg Jackson
Jaffar emo wrestling coach and Brandon
Gibson all jump solo also I made him go
take the course and jump and Brandon was
deathly scared of heights but he did it
and Greg was right there with me let's
roll and did they say it was the best
time ever
ah Greg wants to do it again Brandon
said he's done it check mark will never
do it again that's fair and me I love
every second I'll do it today
you love it love it this is the craziest
feeling man craziest feeling I don't lie
in the canopy that's like the most
boring part to me when
cruisin yeah just like [ __ ] floating
boring you can pull it do you like
little tricks and spins the [ __ ] but the
free phone is where it's at man
[ __ ] backflips and spinning anything
your little my so of course I'm watching
Point Break and still standard not like
I have to do this but what you can't do
what they have in the movie Point Reyes
talk like yeah yeah that's about chaos
is the right word yeah well I would like
you dude pull your cord Shack like
that's not happening out of like a
chance ever have you do you know a guy
named Andy stump now I'm almost scared
to introduce you to because Andy was a
former Navy SEAL now he's the like the
leading guy and far as far as those
squirrel suits the jumpsuit yes he's I
need 200 Jeff's in the world before you
can get into one of those he's like one
of the best in the world have you ever
seen the [ __ ] he does the guys almost
touch the leaves you shouldn't go by to
him he has I think at the time someone
might have beat it but he was the guy
who was in that red bull suit who jumped
off like basically from the moon oh yes
he's that dude he's been on here and you
know what the people don't ever have
what the the rocket he was in they just
left that float is still up there
yeah it's space you know these guys [ __ ]
you I just don't want our trash a couple
hundred million dollars they just say
we're gonna put you this rocket you jump
out and throw a little sticker on it and
call it a day Red Bull covers that I
assume but he was saying how like he
does all these crazy jumps in the suits
are expensive his [ __ ] and he has to get
used to the suit and does all these
jumps but he was saying when he gets
there like people with barely in the
experience are there and he will look at
people like you know you're gonna die
right that's me he looks really like you
know like it's just in a matter of time
I assume you how many times you can jump
yeah the guy I've jumped like whatever a
hundred times that you you know died
yeah that's gonna be me you love that
[ __ ] he would look at me and say you're
but I'm the guy that I did you're too
smart for that Co no I have someone said
cowboy well here's the thing with jump
that's why I never said there's no like
jump police there's not someone
give you a ticket for putting the school
on so all I got to do is find someone
wild enough to give me their squirrel
suit and I'm out of here
he said you can buy I think you buy one
off like eBay or some [ __ ] like the oh
that's super sketchy a used one only
three flies on this one here yeah yeah
but he said the thing is I kissed suits
like the little makes a difference so
like you do right when you should or
whatever yeah like he has to warm up
when you pull your rib cord right
whatever hat actually maybe with your
right hand you have to counteract with
your left hand so when you go to pull
your chute you need to bring your right
hand in front your hand look at your
altimeter grab your chute and pull it
because one hand here put you into like
a spin right like so any little motion I
could only imagine wearing a canopy
doing it you just if you got spun out of
control or just be crazy all in here we
were talking about it and he goes yeah
bringing up we brought on YouTube and he
was like look at this guy and we're
watching a guy just goes over he's like
laughs and I'm like what's wrong with
you he's just a crazy [ __ ] he's awesome
but he's crazy I'm scared to introduce
you too because I feel like you two
would come up with some sort of that
should be a reality show yeah you two
trying to just not die not dying
there you go I got a lot of [ __ ] I got a
lot of [ __ ] to do left in life so I
don't I'm not gonna die well that's why
I don't want to introduce you to an
because any bike oh how about this
cowboy I feel like you might be more
crazy than he is you know I'm saying
when you see my back ripple and I pull
myself up like a champ like a chimp
thirty times fast while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it's a gift it's a gift